well just two days ago an anonymous
op-ed writer in The New York Times as
you well know revealed that he is part
of a resistance inside the executive
branch it's dedicated to sabotaging the
policies of the administration the left
was thrilled by this now they're calling
for the immediate removal of the
president we don't need an election or
even an impeachment trial they're
telling us the cabinet can just end
Trump's presidency right now it's that
simple
okay so Washington wants to remove a
democratically elected president because
they don't like his policies and they
want to do it without any election of
the room it sounds more like a coup than
a feature of a legitimate democracy but
that's what they're calling for maybe
they'll succeed in it but before that
happens the people hoping to regain
power should have to explain why their
ideas are better for America so far they
haven't done that they've talked a lot
about norms called a lot of people
racist and try to make anyone who
disagrees with them shut up and of
course they've lectured us endlessly
about something called diversity as if
that answers some relevant question our
diversity
patchwork heritage is not a weakness it
is still and always will be one of our
greatest strengths our diversity is one
of our greatest strengths our great
strength lies in our diversity we know
our diversity is a strength not a
weakness well they all agree on that
it's hard to know exactly what it means
though other than stop talking or else
we won't stop talking if the president's
gonna be removed from office without a
single vote from anybody outside
Washington DC then we deserve to have
some simple questions answered and we
meet answered for real not just with a
sneer and a ticket to the HR department
for sensitivity training so here goes
first how is our current immigration
system made America more stable and more
prosperous in your answer please explain
what happened to the state of California
used to be called the Golden State had a
thriving middle class at the country's
best schools now the schools in
California are a complete disaster the
middle class is vanishing and the
nation's the largest mass of
impoverished people remains behind
to survey tiny pool of tech oligarchs
how exactly did that happen next how
precisely is diversity or strength since
you've made this our new national motto
please be specific as you explain it can
you think for example of other
institutions such as I don't know
marriage or military units in which the
less people have in common the more
cohesive they are do you get along
better with your neighbors your
co-workers if you can't understand each
other or share no common values please
be honest as you answer this question
and if diversity is our strength why is
it okay for the rest of us to surrender
one of our central rights freedom of
speech to the stay handful of tech
monopolies and by the way if your ideas
are so obviously true why does anyone
who question them need to be shamed
silenced and fired how about this
question after spending two centuries
overcoming our country's painful history
of racial discrimination in hatred why
is it once again acceptable even
encouraged to attack people on the basis
of their skin color and by the way since
we're asking if it's now possible to
change your sex is it possible to change
your race too if not tell us why and be
specific after spending more than a
trillion dollars in thousands of lives
attacking Afghanistan Iraq and Libya and
getting nothing for it
why does it now make sense to start new
wars in Syria and Iran and after 30
years after the Berlin Wall fell why
should we still treat Russia as our main
enemy while completely ignoring China
which actually is and how about this how
is it fair to use public resources to
bail out reckless financial institutions
that caused the last economic collapse
which other enterprises are eligible for
tax dollars once they go bankrupt
because of stupid decisions since we're
living by this principle does it apply
to my household budget for example and
this is San Francisco better off covered
in hypodermic needles and human waste is
Baltimore better off since the police
there decided to stop enforcing the law
Howard Detroit in Gary Indiana doing
weren't you in charge of those cities
we've got a lot more questions we could
go on but we're going to start with
those before canceling democracy
Washington should answer
those questions first and we're going to
start by asking them of Quentin James
who's the found reflective pack and he's
nice enough to join us tonight and
thanks a lot for coming on thank you for
having her so we hear a lot about Trump
is bad we're breaking norms a lot of
that I'll defend some of it I won't
defend I don't work for Trump
why would I defend it but what we never
hear about is the ideas of the people
who seek to take his place
to regain power and they're the people
who came up with all the ideas that the
public rejected to the extent that they
elected Donald Trump so my question is
have they reputed they aided those ideas
that public doesn't want unrestricted
mass low wage immigration our Democrats
against it now I mean have their views
changed what are they for I guess is my
question to you thank you so much for
having me on Tucker I think first
remember that that Hillary Clinton got
more votes than Donald Trump so I don't
know if the Republic repudiated the
entire Democratic platform there 61
million people it's a significant chunk
I would say no of course right but she
still got three million more votes but
neither here nor there president Trump
is our president listen I think when it
comes to what Democrats believe in I'm
really excited about November when
Democrats will take over Congress and
we're gonna see a Democratic agenda move
forward one that's talking about raising
the minimum wage one is talking about
reforming our immigration system dealing
with our health care costs that are
rising right now I think what we've seen
over the past two years from Donald
Trump is a complete almost shutdown of
Congress moving forward and moving
anything substantial politically in
terms of policy way I thought that we're
mad because Congress has done all these
evil things and wrecked the country I
don't you might want to recheck her
talking points in that but I'm not I'm
not here to talk about Trump or Congress
we spent all of our time talking about
that I want to know for example are
Democrats who backed the bailouts of the
banks in 2008 are they committed to not
doing that again Democrats who supported
killing Qaddafi and Libya's appear to
support the bombing of Syria talking
about a war with Iran and Russia have
they really thought this at all are they
still the war party as look we are not
here to I'm not here to defend
policy from the last administration I
think what we're all challenged with
right now is our current administration
and a again almost complete standstill
in terms of moving legislation forward I
think if you look around the nation
where we have Democrats who are leading
some of our cities leading some of our
states they're really taking these
issues to the forefront and again moving
things forward but you make a fair point
you're right and I think they should
fund the wall immediately I'm sure you
agree with me he ran on it I wanna let's
build that no I think when you say
Congress is enacting that's what you're
saying but let me just ask you this so
we have a kind of case study here
because the state of California our big
estate is a one-party state run entirely
by Democrats it was the richest state
when I grew up there it's now got more
poverty than any state it's billions in
debt it will never repay and its cities
are cesspools so would you say that
that's a model for the rest of the
country Tucker the last I checked I
think Governor Brown has a surplus for
the first time in years in California's
budget just to clarify California has
more debt obligations than this country
could pay so no there's no that means a
surplus that's just like it that's just
ridiculous
any asking of the effects no but look
again I don't think we should look at
one state as a model to run our entire
nation well why not it's a democratic
state is the biggest state I mean no
again we're not here to confuse the
issues of California will become the
United States right now okay so named
okay okay then I'll just I'll make it
easy for you name a place the Democrats
have run for at least twenty years and
tell me reassure me that America will
become more like that place look I think
if we look at the past two democratic
presidencies of Bill Clinton and
President Barack Obama the economy No
look at look at the economy look at the
jobs numbers right Donald Trump
inherited an amazing economy George Bush
niro amazing economy and now like if we
look at what's happening in the country
the the the the he's taking credit for
what we saw the Barack Obama it's all
right we like a chance
the past presidents a little too all
right Quentin thank you so much for
joining us I appreciate thank you so
much doctor